Okay, so we're just playing in the browser,
and we had a couple of annoyances.
They were: We can't share the success link
and we can't reload the page without an annoying message.
The way we work around this issue is by using a redirect.
Instead of rendering the result in the post,
we send them to another page that says thanks.
So remember I drew this picture before of you and the servers making requests,
or you and your browser.
We made that first request, the get request for the form, and then the server responded
with the form HTML.
You posted your answer, and then if you submitted something correct,
the browser responded with the success message.
Now, this seems simple and nice, but as we said,
if you respond to a post with content you've got these two major limitations.
The link doesn't share well, and you can't reload the page.
Now imagine we weren't doing a contrived example like entering dates into text boxes.
Instead we were adding a new blog post to our blog.
We'd want to be able to see our blog post once we submit it.
We want to be able to link to that blog post.
We want to be able to reload that page without editing our blog post.
Every time you post something to the server, the server has to do some work.
We don't want the server to have to do that work of validating our date every time
over and over just when we want to see our success message.
So instead of returning the success HTML, we return a redirect.
We'll send a redirect to go to a different URL, our success page,
to which the server will respond with our success HTML.
Now, you may think the old way had only 2 round trips: Get, post, answer.
The new way has: Get, post, and get the success page.
So that's three round trips, but we can avoid both of these issues.